No coach <inaudible>, we're gonna be covering BBC's hard talk, which is a, um,
it's a terrible name for a show.
I was thinking the same thing, bro. Thank you very much for acknowledging that.
I just read it out loud. I said bro, hot talk. Uh, so, uh,
the show is a basic show with didn't.
Bring on somebody in the ask them difficult questions. And as a result,
it's called BBC heart talk.
Racial observations have very much formed at least in the early stages,
the backbone of your standup, uh, comedy career.
Do you now regret some of the jokes you made? And let me give you an example.
You said my mother black south African was saying, get me a white guy,
get a white guy. Well, my father was white Swiss. Of course he liked chocolate.
That sounds funny to me. Even when you say it, that sounded really funny.
Why would I regret.
That? Why would you regret that?
Because some people say that's not really very funny.
But the people laugh. Everyone can say something is not really funny.
This is the way some people don't like.
But isn't important. Okay. Let me you an example. We have a,
a very well established black comedian in the Britain called Lenny Henry. Yes.
And he has said that he regrets doing that kind of joke where he said he would
wipe his, who cares.
It's two different people, one regrets. So what.
He has said that regrets doing that kind of joke,
where he said he would wipe his sweating brow and say, huh,
I'm leaking chocolate. He.
Oh, but that's but that's D but that's different. Well, it's not,
it's using chocolate, isn't it? But, but that is, but that is different. Well,
the Swiss love chocolate is not a term that you're referring to.
Skin color as chocolate. What he.
Says, because my mom is proud to beautiful chalk. That's what she's saying.
And this is, if you in the book, I talk about this as well. I go,
I saw people and race as chalking. I wouldn't use that.
But use that. I'm that color. I wouldn't say that.
When I, when I grew up.
Yo, it's like talking,
it's like listening to a French person from speaking in English.
That's the, that's the, that's the mall.
It's just like, I wouldn't say that. So you shouldn't said that, like,
I don't feel comfortable saying that.
So why should you feel comfortable saying that? You're not the same.
Oh, and her defense,
the show is normally geared towards asking at hitting questions.
But I think one of the points of asking hard hitting questions also to listen to
other person's reply and then retort,
it's not enough for you to just have a bunch of things that you've prepared to
fire at the person to put them in uncomfortable situations.
You also have to go back and forth with what they're actually saying and listen.
So I think that's like one of the mistakes that she's making for me watching
this.
When I grew up, I believed that all people were chocolates.
My mom was dark chocolates. My dad was white chocolate and I was Mo chocolates.
So I see all people. So people.
So you see as funny,
but do you not realize that some people might not like that.
And Lenny Henry went on to say that joke about how he was leaking chocolate.
He says, I knew there had to be a better way. And you know.
Some people are gonna have lines at the arbitrary giant for their own comedy.
I have no problem with it. If you get up on stage and you say,
I never want to make handicapped jokes,
cuz my son's handicapped or I don't think it's acceptable. Don't do it.
And a handicapped do it in a wheelchair will come on stage right after you make
a budget jokes about being handicapped. People make jokes about everything.
I mean I've seen videos where like, you know, uh,
Weinstein survivors come out and make jokes about Weinstein. Yes.
That's the thing.
There's actual entirety. Comedy shows like that.
People laugh at their own trauma. They laugh at other people's trauma.
It happens. That's humor. That's comedy. That's how it works.
If you say you don't wanna do something, that's okay.
That's when you start telling people, you shouldn't do that.
You should regret that you shouldn't listen.
I could find a bunch of people as corn, as terrible as I want to.
I would never think of saying they shouldn't be able,
allowed to make those jokes ever. I even get up here. I'm like,
I don't like it. That's okay. It's just when people are like,
you should regret this, you should take it back then. I'm.
Like, nah,
it's the same ever was people that really try to enforce religion on you.
It's the same thing. I don't eat pork. So you shouldn't eat pork? No,
if you don't want to eat pork, we'll do it over there. That's your thing. Yeah.
Don't have to impose it on me. Leave, leave.
All that gel in filled candy.
For me of trying to put the message over,
putting your jokes over without having to pick on people because of their color
or because of their race. Yes. But is his view?
His view is different from yours because he's Lenny Henry and I'm Trevor Noah.
Yeah. He's also, he is black. Yes.
But he was talking about leaking chocolate implying.
You said, he said, yeah, but he's black.
Like we're all supposed to agree with the same people.
Like all supposed to be like, we all view racial issues the same way. Yeah.
Yeah. You're different. But you're black. So yes. Yes. You're black.
As you live in the UK, dumbest Africa, the dumbest argument.
That I, the black experience in those two countries is vastly different.
You're not going see things the same way.
And even if the experience is the same,
you're not necessarily gonna live it the same way that.
His skin color was not something that belonged to him. That is a different job.
It's trying to say that his skin color is chocolate. No, no, no, no.
You're splitting hairs hair. And here.
Here, here she is. She's the one that's sitting here.
And the worst thing is that she's not even taking account like about context.
I hear chocolate chocolate, same thing, no context. You said chocolate,
common denominator chocolate. So
she can't hear nothing else with chocolate. She said, chocolate,
you said chocolate. You feel the same. You used to feel the same. You,
you sound very smart, but this is pretty dumb arguments. You're gonna hear.
This from me. You're gonna hear this from every comic context is everything.
It's everything.
Especially the comedy you hear or a certain comedian outside of a context,
you're gonna think he's a up person. Guess what?
It's very normal for the type of comedy shows he goes to,
they like that kind of humor. Right?
You see a woman on the street might think she's weird.
And the places in the circles that she goes to do,
her work perfectly except context. Everything is contextual.
You can't just take words and lines out of some special you saw or some comedy
show that someone wrote about that you read in newspaper and got outraged over.
It's not the way it works. Okay.
Doing, because what you're doing is creating. I'm not sure.
Either you're creating.
I'm not sure. I would say no. You're creating monoliths.
You're creating mono of jokes and that's not fair to do.
Every single joke has a context.
Every single joke comes from a place.
The most important thing with comedy is context. Without context,
no conversation is complete without context. No communication can,
but somebody could take.
That out of context. Yeah. I'm putting it to you then. Are you not.
Then don't.
No, no, but that's your problem. If you take something outta context,
that's your issue. You know what I mean? It's like, here's what happens?
You see some dude going to a woman be like, Hey baby, why you doing?
Everyone's like, Hey, you. What? Don't talk to her like that.
That's my girlfriend. Oh, well you shouldn't have called her baby. It's like,
no. You should've minded your business. That's his girlfriend.
Just cuz you don't know the context of the relationship. You just assumed.
That's all you. He's talking to his woman.
That's that's his that's is the same thing. The same thing. It's the same thing.
But I took it out. The context. Yeah. That's you, you taking it outta context.
That's you, you taking it outta.
<Laugh>. No that's you though. It is that's.
You,
you taking it outta the context is the equivalent of you not mind your business.
No mind your.
Business. Given what Len Henry said,
are you not guilty perhaps with some of your routines or a joke like that?
Reinforcing prejudices and promoting stereotypes in the minds of people who
may be inclined to think like that. And then they'll think, oh,
Trevor Noah says his mother's chocolate.
I'm gonna go around saying that to my black friends.
And they might take offense. You could be reinforcing prejudice.
You could be doing anything. If you are not doing the opposites,
how you are, uh, action is implied.
Does not define what you were doing.
Okay. Let's look at another aspect of race.
You moved just a few years ago to the United States. Your,
your routine is a comedian. Um,
often mimicked Africans and also African Americans. And about African Americans,
you have said this.
You know what? This is like. It's like somebody going to N and be like,
so tell us about how you, uh, the police. The went
Tang. Why aren't you something to be with you imagine going to two it time.
Be like, so when you made, hit it up,
tell us about how you his and the cl that he claimed
side. What do you mean by that, sir? <laugh> stupid. Huh?
So biggie claimed to be a player, but you his wife.
Really? Yeah. Okay. Did you really.
Come straight from Compton or did you not come from the womb
of your mother?
Like me? You, you, you ah, yo.
So juvenile, when you say back that up
Michael DEPA, when the thing.
Goes.
Are you advocating for gun violence, stupid
future. When you go,
Would you say that that was where lyrics from the future? <laugh>.
That? I hated that I know when I burned that bar.
Yo.
Americans, you have said they is, you are not African, but we play along.
It's a very loose term, African American.
Because half the time you use it for people who aren't even African,
as long as you are black, they say African American,
I didn't deliver it like that. You're not doing my jokes trust. Okay. Right.
Yeah. I'm not.
Exactly you, you you're bad at it. And you're taking outta context. Therefore,
we can't have this conversation with you. You can't have a conversation lady.
If your, your points and everything that you're saying is always outta context.
You're gonna take a joke and you're gonna change after.
There's a lot of things about comedy that makes comedy work. Okay?
The context that as we discuss is one of them, intonation is another one, right?
Delivery is another one.
The tone that you're gonna use is some something that's.
The reference is gonna be something else. If you take that, all of that,
you make it serious and you take it all that out of this context of comedy,
you make it, it sounded like so serious and you don't deliver it properly.
There's no point no point having this conversation with you lady,
whole point of being on BBC hard talk. I said it the fifth time.
Now this whole interview,
throw it out the garbage cause it's not a real conversation. It's not.
When people come from backgrounds where they're forced to walk on eggshells all
the time.
They don't know what it's like to interact with normal people or hear them talk
what this woman is doing from her high level of education.
Academic background is coming into a world that she doesn't understand.
You're talking about people who are performing in bars and clubs, okay.
In front of a drunk crowd, everyone's rowdy. Just letting loose, having fun.
It's a different world. The way people communicate amongst each other,
the looseness of it all. You need to understand that. Cuz you know,
when you work in a corporate environment, a simple joke can get you fired.
Cuz somebody took it the wrong way. When you don't come from the same world,
you look at it through your lens, you start clouding everything. Sarcasm.
Doesn't really have a place in the workplace, right? That kind of humor.
That kind of darkness doesn't have a place in academia in a lot of ways.
You're not allowed. Trust me. There's literal policies,
but now you're coming to a different place. The way he delivered that, right?
He might have been playful with it. He might have been teasing.
The black audience that was present. He.
Might, might be sarcastic with it.
But if you deliver in a flat tone, try reading a painting.
Oh, is this a lady on the wall? No Combs.
<Laugh> you know, it's not even just the painting,
the era it was done in who did it?
What was the historical context of the time that they did it?
All that matters to the painting? Oh, it's.
Just screaming on the a boat. No Vango. <laugh>
Vango. Calm down.
No, no, no but you see's but.
I'm just asking, are they not African.
American? Here's the here's here's what you're missing.
What you're doing right now is the equivalent me saying
now it's raining more than now ever. Uh, I'll be here with you forever.
You can always be my friend standing under my umbrella. Ella, Ella, Ella, Ella,
Ella, Ella, Ella, Ella, a a a, a, a L Ella, Ella, a a a a,
I seem like a mad person right now because I'm not doing everything that was
within the context of the song umbrella by Rihanna. When you were doing comedy,
merely I words, I spoke it, my eyes, my voice,
my connection with an audience is completely different.
People can see when you are being playful.
People can see when you are saying something, being playful about that,
that you don't believe. That is what Sati is though.
You're poking holes. So you PO point I'm trying to make is that there was a,
a shift amongst the black American community to start calling themselves African
American. They didn't want a definition by default. I U are not white.
So therefore you were black. Yes.
They wanted to have a hyphenated identity that linked them with the continent of
their ancestors. And therefore, when you say, oh,
they're not really African they're playing along,
you cannot disconnect what you say from this debate.
That's really, you know, captured the imagination, thinking in 2014 Chimamanda,
and Goche the celebrated Nigerian author.
She said that when she visited the us,
she felt that her African American classmate was annoyed with her because she
didn't share their anger.
And she said that she was not burdened herself.
I America's terrible racial history.
That difference does it result in the African Americans
who've arrived recently in the United States,
such as itself acting differently or having a different psyche from the black
Americans who were the descendants of slaves and have lived for many,
many years, obviously in the us.
I will say this. I will be careful to not, uh,
comment on the experience of every single person, because I'm only myself.
And I can only experience the people that are around me.
What I do know is this in terms of our racial histories,
South Africa and America are very similar when I.
Talk. Right. So what did.
You think? I just wanted don't don't be her. Let him finish. How many?
Just kidding, man.
Yeah. So what.
Do you think? Uh, she was obnoxious. Uh, I, I like,
I'd like to come in, uh, Trevor Noah for keeping this cool.
Cuz she was me to off just right from the start. Just let,
not letting you really like the sound of your voice. You really do lady.
Like not letting him speak every time he will. He had a point on you like,
oh that's interesting, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Like let him finish.
Let him finish.
Uh, they'll come for everything. They'll the first they'll start here.
They'll go for music very soon.
They've been trying to go for video games or gonna try to police out all.
They'll try to police every idea, everything that comes outta your mouth.
And they'll try to make like, listen personally, me personally,
I don't watch most stand up comedies and think, oh my God, this is so profound.
It's like really affected my worldview.
Normally I just go there laughing at leave.
Sometimes they might make like a single good point,
but I'm not going there to have all my opinions changed. Okay.
For these people go to these comedy shows and be like.
Mind blowing.
You're gonna vote for Hillary. Now. It's like,
what I just said to sometimes when I travel to the south,
they like shooting shotguns outside of their truck. I mean, that's it.
And I think it's funny who cares?
Some of you need to lighten up. Y'all need to uh, no.
Take the stick out your. Okay. Go to a comedy show,
buy a vibrator. Pleasure yourself. Okay.
And leave your company policy at your company. When you get off work,
stay off work.
Cuz some of you guys walk around like HRS looking over your shoulder and you're
talking kid is too. Oh.
If I laugh at this joke, I'm gonna get fired. Calm down.
It's not that deep.
The same stuff that she's talking about right now is a lot of the same stuff
you're hearing about Chappelle or other comedians in regards to what they can or
can't say on stage, I got, got shut up, shut up. But anyways,
that's my thoughts. What do you think? I said what? I said,
let us know what you guys think of the commons fan.
Yo, if that lady what was interviewing me, I'd be like.
But that's a show also. It is, it is hard talk. So that's a show.
You, you smart weight. <laugh> that's a show. I know it's a show,
but it's, if you go on, I'll be like, wow, you, you,
you really look smart, but you are dumb as rocks.